watch this I'm going to show you
something really fasting do me a favor
Web Summit I want you to stand up if the
following statement is true I know some
of you are [ __ ] lazy but it's good
circulation so if this is true to you
stand up how many people here now
actually get upset when another human
being
calls them stand up gonna wait
I want everybody don't sit down yet I
want everybody look at this these are
human beings I'm gonna repeat it to
everybody these are human beings that
actually get upset when another person
calls them the main way we're old just
five or six years ago let's clap it up
for these pioneers I'll tell you why I'm
clapping for that pioneer right there
I'm clapping because what these people
have it innately felt and understood is
the emergence of the most important
asset in our new ecosystem along with
the health of our family money our
religion and the health which is time
the reason those people stood up and
were mad that somebody called them is
because we have technology now that
allows us to actually text somebody and
I'll call you back on my time don't call
me on your time like literally like
[ __ ] I'll text you back mom that kind
of [ __ ] and so we as business people in
corporate America need to wrap our head
around one very big truth the day of
advertising stealing somebody's time is
over